[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du club de la presse
sur tv 78 rendez vous que vous suivez
également sur radio sensations sur l fm
aujourd'hui pour commenter l'actualité
yvelinoise à mes côtés alexandre marqué
journalistes pour toutes les nouvelles
et 7,8 actus.fr bonjour alexandre
bonjour acquis mahaya rédactrice en chef
de l fm
bonjour hakima rongeurs nouradine agne
pour marmite fm 88 4 du côté de de
trappes
bonjour également ça nous permet de
vérifier que le son fonctionnent bien en
même temps nicolas kirillovitch bonjour
vous êtes journaliste pour radio
sensations 98 kg d'or à tous et nicolas
landry qui lui est en plateau
journalistes pour tv 78 bonjour nicolas
bonjour à tous vous êtes aussi
responsable de l'émission économique sur
notre antenne le sky échos voici le
sommaire pour ce mois de novembre
confinement acte de la france à nouveau
assignée à résidence mais car il ya un
mais les écoles sont ouvertes
le travail peut se poursuivre plus
largement et plusieurs magasins restent
ouverts de quoi susciter des
incompréhensions de la part de la
population et de faire naître aussi une
certaine contestation
samuel pâtit professeur d'histoire au
collège assassiné en pleine rue à
conflans sainte honorine par un
islamiste et le pays tout entier bascule
à nouveau dans l' angoisse de nouveaux
attentats terroristes et puis l'élection
américaine aussi mais vu des yvelines
les expatriés aussi ont fait leur choix
retour sur ce scrutin très serré et puis
nous vous dévoilerons aussi à nos
personnalités locales du mois nous
évoquerons les sujets prochainement à la
une dans vos médias locaux
[Musique]
à la fin du confinement reste fixée au
1er décembre déclarations de jean castex
tout peu de temps après l'allocution du
président macron et c'est bien la seule
chose plutôt clair en ce moment les
dérogations à voir même les entorses au
confinement sont nombreuses pour débuter
j'aimerais un peut avoir le sentiment de
chacun sur votre vote votre perception
un petit peu sur ce confinement est ce
que vous avez le sentiment d'une
certaine résignation au contrat d'une
contestation de la population aussi
peut-être comment vous vous le vivez
aussi ce confinement
nicolas kirillovitch je pense que c'est
les deux alors c'est un peu une réponse
de normand mais il ya il ya une
résignation du fed et des chiffres un
sanitaire qui conte difficile à
contester et puis quand même ce
mécontentement sur sur cette cacophonie
au sein du gouvernement mais aussi ce
côté peut-être un peu un peu français
qui marche si dans les yvelines où où on
demande à être protégé et en même temps
on a du mal à accepter les mesures qui
implique cette protection donc
donc j'ai envie de dire les deux
sentiments même au même dans les
yvelines qui n'est pas à part dans la
france et à qui va justement du côté
d'une note du nord du département
comment les vécu un peu se confirme en
ce moment écoutez nous on a réalisé un
micro-trottoir comme comme on le fait
régulièrement dans notre programme un
faux lac aux actus pour justement de
sonder la population grâce à ce
confinement est ce qui ressort
globalement c'est quelque chose de très
séduit en même temps comme on dirait il
ya du soulagement
et puis en même temps une perplexité
faut le dire sur l'efficacité de cette
formule parce qu'il ya quand même une
différence entre le premier confinement
celui qu'on a vécu au mois de mars
et c'est ce qui ressort des différents
des différents témoignages
et puis également ce qui ressort c'est
que la perception est très différente en
fonction de si on est retraité bien
entendu si on est étudiant
si on est actif puisque ce qu'on voit
clairement dans les rues c'est que les
artères sont encore pleines les les axes
routiers sont encore pleins on n'a pas
le sentiment n'a pas la perception d'un
confinement
on va peut-être écouté le micro-trottoir
vous avez réalisé justement pour pour l
fm
on écoute ce son qui nous a été envoyé
par l fm est bien bien et mal parce qu
on est rassuré d'une certaine façon
parce qu'il a été remis en place
c'est pas facile à vivre on va juste
essayer de vivre avec mais ce n'est pas
face de france ou encore c'est difficile
pour nous en tant que retraité
on a pu un peu plus en appui de loisirs
on n'a plus le droit de faire de sport
on n'a plus droit d'aller à la piscine
on a plus grande rien faire sortir une
heure c'est quoi dans une dans une
journée
non justement je trouve qu'il est moins
dur non par rapport à mes enfants fait
qu'ils sont scolarisés c'était assez
difficile par rapport à mon fils qui est
qui était aussi en fait que pendant le
premier et confinement est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui suffisant on se pose encore
des questions parce que vu le monde
qu'il y a dans la journée qui se promène
donc est il aujourd'hui suffisant voilà
c'est la question
voilà pour ces quelques réactions dans
le nord du département si on revient sur
sur sud un petit peu sur saint quentin
en yvelines par exemple alexandre ex ans
de marquer pour pour les nouvelles et
7,8 actu vous sur le terrain vous avez
auquel est qu un peu on parlait aussi de
ses retraités est ce que ce sont eux qui
se sont peut-être un peu plus punis
aussi que les autres parce que je reste
vraiment à domicile puisqu'ils ne
travaille pas oui c'est peut-être les
les salles finalement qui sort pas parce
qu'effectivement on n'a pas l'impression
d'être confiné cela ressemble plus à un
couvre-feu finalement qu'à un quart un
confinement
avec encore des bouchons la circulation
l'activité économique quand on lit les
écoles toutes pratiques et finalement
c'est peut-être pour ça que que c'est
compliqué pour l'instant que les lacs a
ramené contentement parce que y'en a qui
comprennent pas que des commerces dits
essentiels restent ouverts alors que
d'autres qu'elle soit fermée et je pense
c'est ça qui crée cette incompréhension
c'est ce sentiment d'injustice chez
certains il faut la tenderie pour tv 78
aussi une incompréhension du fait que le
gouvernement ait
le président macron a annoncé le
confinement et puis le gouvernement a
annoncé le plan mais un plan en quelque
sorte incomplet parce qu'il ya encore
des débats ce week-end on se rappelle
autour des librairies notamment les
grandes enseignes qui avaient le droit
encore de vendre les livres notamment
les enseignes spécialisées dans le
secteur culturel
alors que les petites librairies et les
petits commerçants les libraires
notamment présents sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines ont dû
s'adapter on prend par exemple la
librairie du pavé du canal qui s'est
adaptée qui fait du click and collect
c'est à dire que les clients commandent
de leurs livres en ligne et vienne le
chercher dans le magasin alors voilà
après il ya deux cas de figure il ya des
commerçants qui qui sont en colère parce
que leurs commerces sont obligatoirement
fermé fermée administrativement mais
certains s'adaptent quand même au delà
de ça il ya une certaine incompréhension
qui est aussi alimentée par les élus par
les maires alors là on va faire
peut-être un petit tour de table aussi
pour voir un peu comment vole les élus
sur vos différents secteurs dans le
département ont réagi mais il ya des
arrêtés qui ont été pris des arrêtés qui
sont au final il est beau puisqu'ils
sont cassés après par les préfets mais
mais on entend dans certains petits
commerces sont restés ouverts nouradine
par exemple peut-être sur sur trappe
comme on s'est positionné le maire de
trappes sur ces questions là est ce
qu'il lui il a pris un arrêté par
exemple pour ouvrir ces petits commerces
est ce que il s'est rangé derrière les
skis étaient énoncées par le
gouvernement non il s'est rangé derrière
ce qui avait été annoncé et ce qu'elle a
mis en avant c'était surtout voilà la
préparation ce site à l'impréparation du
gouvernement notamment concernant les
masques dans les écoles pour les pour
les petits à partir de 6 ans voilà c'est
surtout ce qui a été mis en avoir et du
coup la mairie tram à acheter et des des
commandes et des petits masques adapté
aux petits dans les écoles primaires
notamment et on a fait la distribution
donc voilà c'est surtout ça qui a été
mise en avant puis après le travail de
solidarité eau et qu'elle manquait très
important en cette période il n'y a pas
eu de décision spécifique concernant les
concernant les commerçants je sais qu'il
a
je sais qu'il a signé la tribune de
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
en estimant qu'il fallait des règles
claires et justes et que de nombreux
commerces de proximité ne pourrait pas
survivre un second rang confinement il
ya des élus alexandre dans le
département aussi qui ont pris des
arrêtés
oui il ya eu le maire de lyme est le
meilleur maison d'un fils de jacques
myard mais comme vous le disiez wilfried
tout ça ça risque d'être retoqué
parce que l'arrêté qui sont jugés
illégaux et utilise d'être retoqué par
le tribunal administratif de versailles
partie de la gauche puisque ça fait ça
fait ça fait ça fait une semaine par
exemple pour le pour l'arrêter ali mais
qu'il était qu'il a été présenté par la
mairie une semaine plus tard les
commerces
visiblement puisque hier j'étais en
contact avec la mairie sont toujours
sont toujours ouverts et l'arrêté n'a
toujours pas été retoqué donc si c'est
pour qu'il soit retoquée dans une
semaine et qui emmanuel macron annonce
au bout de 15 jours comme il l'a dit que
les commerces pourront ouvrir ça sera ça
serait une opération réussie par exemple
pour le maire de limay à moins que ce
soit un confinement plus durs qui soient
annoncées aussi dans une semaine
nicolas justement au niveau des recours
auprès du tribunal administratif mais
aussi auprès du conseil d'état
il ya de nombreux recours qui sont qui
sont effectuées et notamment nous on a
reçu sur notre plateau monseigneur bruno
valentin l'évêque auxiliaire de
versailles qui fait partie de ces
évêques donc de la conférence des
évêques de france qui ont fait un
recours référé liberté auprès du conseil
d'état pour permettre l'organisation des
messes du dimanche 1 donc il ya aussi il
ya les commerçants et lé maire mais il
ya aussi le milieu religieux et
notamment le milieux catholiques et
chrétiens qui déposent des recours pour
permettre l'organisation des messes du
dimanche alors que lors du premier
confinement on l'avait vu certaines
messes étaient retransmises par
visioconférence seulement les les
personnes d'église étaient présentes
dans l'église et les
les fidèles pouvaient suivre la
célébration par ordinateur nous allons
continuer ce club de la presse du mois
de novembre et nous allons continuer à
échanger avec les journalistes des
différents médias du département autour
pour l'instant de cette question du
confinement confinement sur fond
forcément de crise sanitaire on pourrait
quand même faire une petite parenthèse
pour parler du personnel soignant hakima
je me tourne vers vous puisque vous avez
rencontré du personnel soignant pour
évoquer un petit peu la situation
actuelle oui tout à fait à l'équipe de
meulan les mureaux qui qui a souhaité
nous a l'air complètement sur la
situation de grosse crise qu'il vivait
avec une saturation bon alors ça ça
rejoint ce qu'on vend temps déjà au
niveau national avec l'annoncé cette
semaine de plus de 80% 85 % des lits de
réanimation qui seraient occupés alors
au niveau local en tout cas en ce qui
concerne l'hôpital de meulan les deux
bourreaux c'est ce que notre journaliste
reporter effectué effectivement a
constaté avec des lits dans les couloirs
avec avec finalement des des patients
relativement jeune entre 35 et 40 ans
donc une une deuxième vague
effectivement qui est plus dur et
justement on a on a extrait d'un
reportage pour entendre les réactions de
ses plus personnel soignant qui est
véritablement à bout on n'est pas comme
vous pouvez le voir on est débordé
aujourd'hui on a une collègue est quand
même qui est venu à travailler ce soir
parce qu'elle n'avait pas le choix on
lui a pas laissé le choix alors qu'elle
est positif
actuellement je suis en poste mais je
suis en congé ou survenu hier
aujourd'hui je reviens dimanche soir
mercredi prochain enfin on compte plus
les heures dans lesquels on revient on
n'a même pas de thermomètre notant sûr
mais tu ne marche pas on les fatigue et
on n'est pas aidés et l'art doit encore
survivre à une deuxième vague de cause
ou à la télé on entend que tout va bien
qu'ils essayent de faire leur max leur
maximum qu'avec et qu'ils ont appris de
la première vague tout mais non
on est toujours souffrance au sein de
l'hôpital moi je trouve que cette
deuxième vague est beaucoup plus intense
est beaucoup plus compliqué à gérer que
la première on doit donner de notre
personne de notre temps de notre force
un moment donné faut arrêter faux faux
maîtres et les moyens parce que la santé
n'a pas de prix ni la nôtre n'est celle
des patients on voit la situation dans
les hôpitaux et cette saturation sur sur
les différends liés dans le reste du
département
alexandre peut-être non moi j'ai pas
trop trop d'ego je sais profite juste
pour rebondir puisque vous dit vous
n'avez pas trop d'écho et effectivement
quelques fois c'est difficile d'avoir
les chiffres des hôpitaux ces terres que
la rs communiqué l' agence régionale de
santé
mais quand on contacte les hôpitaux pour
avoir les chiffres très précis c'est un
peu plus compliqué on a plus de mal à
jouer oui mini mini haut et poissy c'est
compliqué je sais que mon collègue de
rambouillet a plus de facilité mais en
passant par les syndicats lessard est
effectivement c'est un vrai problème
pour les journalistes locaux
il ya un mouvement hier visiblement à
rambouillet enfin j'ai vu ça dans la
presse et notamment sur 7 88 y avait un
visiblement un mouvement rambouillet
pour manifester contre le manque de
moyens devant devant de voir l'hôpital
de ségur de la santé aussi concernant
rambouillet où les syndicats de demander
les différentes primes qui n'avait pas
été aussi versées mais qui alertait sur
cette seule cette saturation
même si une fois de plus nos
journalistes locaux vos loyers on a
quelquefois du mal à avoir les chiffres
très précis d'occupation des lits même
si l' agence régionale de santé le
confirmant il ya une saturation alors
pour continuer à discuter autour de
cette crise sanitaire on peut aussi
parler des des enseignants parce que la
rentrée était très particulière pour
tous les élèves et les syndicats
enseignants en tout cas certains ont
appelé aussi à
à tout simplement fermer les écoles si
les protocoles sanitaires n'était pas
renforcée alternance de classe pour
faire simple diviser les groupes avoir
moins de monde dans les écoles il ya eu
quelques mouvements aussi et du côté de
menthe aussi a eu quelques professeurs
qui est encore aujourd'hui sont en grève
absolument et puis surtout des ondées
manifestation de on va dire des mises
émeutes il ya des voitures qui ont brûlé
ou sur différents sites à
mantes-la-jolie mantes la ville
donc on a commencé à avoir effectivement
une agitation
cette semaine on a eu le sentiment que
c'était un peu la semaine test et au
final est écrit plus amplement
et même si on n'a pas pu directement les
syndicats on a eu de notre côté on a eu
des difficultés avec les enseignants du
second degré avec des enseignants du
premier degré au fonds beaucoup moins
globalement ce qui ressort d'une sur
notre secteur dans le mantois
on sait que au niveau du premier degré
les enseignants même si là la situation
est stressante
ils sont quand même favorable au
maintien de l'école avec les masques se
sont dits terres rares coude en ce qui
concerne les collèges et des lycées
c'est là que clairement c'est ingérable
est effectivement là la proposition de
faire à distance avec une journée sur
deux qui sera maintenue comment s'est
passée la rentrée sur vos différents
secteurs made in pour pour marmite dont
la rentrée c'est plutôt s'est plutôt
bien passé alors pour rejoindre un petit
peu aussi ce que disait hakima c'est
vrai que au niveau de l'école primaire
voilà on a eu beaucoup de retours
beaucoup de témoignages légalement à ce
niveau là en disant que c'était
compliqué de 20 de faire respecter des
règles sanitaires pour des enfants
notamment 6 7 ans avec les masques vous
doutez bien que c'est d'ailleurs c'est
l'argument qui avaient été utilisés
initialement dans de la première vague
on disait que ce n'était pas nécessaire
de mettre des noms pas que ce soit pas
efficace mais que ce n'était pas
nécessaire de mettre à des enfants de 6
ou 7 ans parce que justement il était
trop petit et qui n'arrêtait pas de
toucher les masques de les bouger de les
mettre dans leur poche etc et que du
coup c'était ça rendait là inefficace
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé en
élémentaire notamment dans beaucoup de
d'enseignants entend ces mots qui nous
ont dit que c'était très compliqué de
faire respecter cette consigne notamment
et puis au niveau des collèges et des
lycées
le problème qui se pose c'est que quand
vous avez 35 à 40 élèves dans une classe
c'est très compliqué de pouvoir de
pouvoir respecter des distances de
sécurité de pouvoir éviter les brassages
et depuis le pouvoir aussi commence à
faire froid
régulièrement aérer les les salles que
c'est ce qui est ressorti en tout cas
pour pour pour cette rentrée même si
globalement ça s'est plutôt bien passé
il y avait d'ailleurs un appel à
mobilisation il ya nord 1 1 je crois que
c'est le dise si je dis pas de bêtises
une mobilisation nationale
donc voilà affaire à suivre on va
écouter un représentant du syndicat snes
fsu c'était sur notre antenne il y a
quelques jours
d'une part on a eu connaissance du
protocole uniquement jeudi soir donc
c'est extrêmement tardif pendant le
cadre de vacances pour le mettre en
place
d'autre part ce protocole n'est que
prétendument renforcée puisque en fait
il est indiqué à de nombreux endroits
que les mesures sont préconisées et puis
si ce n'est pas possible eh bien on
continue comme avant donc pas parler de
protocoles rembourser et enfin un
certain nombre des mesures qui sont
préconisées sont complètement
inapplicable
c'est à dire que par exemple pour les
mesures du distanciation physique si on
ne diminue pas le nombre d'élèves
présents dans l'établissement
elles sont en fait complètement
impossible à mettre en place puisque on
ne peut pas simplement pousser les murs
pour agrandir les locaux
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est resté aux
gars le plus longtemps possible et ce
que l'on craint c'est que si des mesures
adaptées approprié qui sécurise tous les
élèves et tous les personnels
maintenant si ces mesures ne sont pas
prises effectivement nous allons en
arriver à une fermeture totale des
établissements très rapidement donc nous
ce qu'on demande c'est un protocole est
beaucoup plus strictes et beaucoup plus
sécurisant voilà pour cette intervention
de delphine remaniée du snes fsu c'était
à suivre sur le journal donc journal de
tv 78 nous continuons à faire ce tour
d'horizon et comment voir comment le
confinement cette période sera
confinement est vécue dans le
département des yvelines avec tout de
même un volet important celui de
l'économie la première vague est passé
beaucoup d'entreprises en ont souffert
on le ressent aujourd'hui il ya ce
confinement ce sera forcément beaucoup
plus compliqué aussi pour pour tous ces
chefs d'entreprise ces entrepreneurs
nicolas landry peut-être un petit point
vous avez quelques chiffres justement
mais exactement en quelques chiffres qui
nous viennent de la cci et de la
direccte sur les six premiers mois de
2000 20 il ya 14000 plus de 14 mille
emplois qui ont été perdus dans le
département entre juin et septembre 2000
va donc juin pourquoi on prend ce genre
parce que c'est au moment où on a vécu
le déconfinement le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi a augmenté de 3% depuis le mois
de juin à 116 mille personnes inscrites
selon les chiffres de pôle emploi et au
30 septembre pour les demandes
d'activité partielle il ya 56 % des
entreprises des yvelines qui sont
concernés pour 64 % des salariés
yvelinois impactés alors pour se laisser
ça qui est rassurant vraiment c'est ce
que disent les chefs d'entreprise pour
ce second confinement il ya eu de
nouvelles mesures qui ont été prises
alors des anciennes recettes mais qui
ont été renforcées on passe notamment à
l'activité partielle avec une prise en
charge à 80 4% ça avait baissé un moment
donné la s'est repositionnée à 84 %
c'est-à-dire que l'état prend en charge
80 4% des salaires quand l'entreprise le
demande il ya le fonds de solidarité qui
a été augmentée jusqu'à 10000 euros pour
les entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés
il ya l'exonération des cotisations
sociales
le pge est toujours disponible il a été
prolongé jusqu'au 30 juin
baisieux le prélat renty par les dames
c'est à dire que les entreprises peuvent
demander un prêt auprès de leur banque
ce prêt qui est garantie par l'état et
ça les entreprises peuvent le demander
jusqu'au jusqu'au 30 juin 2021 alors le
psg c'est un peu ce qui tient et ce qui
maintient en vie les entreprises
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que le
remboursement commence seulement un an
après là ça a été les pg ont été
demandés au mois de mars c'est à dire
que à partir de mars 2021 les
entreprises commencent à rembourser ce
prêt donc pour le moment
l'argent a été utilisé ou pas d'ailleurs
parce que certaines entreprises et ça
nous a été confiée par le président
yvelines de la fédération bancaire
française
certaines entreprises ont stocké les
prêts dans leur trésorerie c'est à dire
que cet argent est disponible ils n'ont
pas utilisé et ça concerne aujourd'hui
dans les yvelines dix mille entreprises
et 95 % de ces entreprises sont des tpe
pme
donc c'est vraiment les petites
structures celles qui sont le plus en
danger par rapport à ce deuxième
confinement ça n'empêche pas les plans
sociaux déjà dans certaines entreprises
alexandre il ya eu lieu pour pour toutes
les nouvelles et pour le 7-8 actu vous
avez suivi justement certains certains
mouvements sociaux un petit peu oui
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines ya
eu plusieurs plans sociaux déjà été
annoncées dans le secteur de
l'aéronautique chez perma soit zhao clés
sous voie ferrée à elancourt chez chez
airbus et l'encours aussi avec les st
pierre donc c'est un secteur déjà très
touché mesdames on risque avec ce second
confinement au risque d'y avoir encore
des faillites des fermetures des plans
de restructuration dans d'autres
domaines
je pense par exemple il ya aline et là
aussi qu'elle a annoncé un plan ou clés
sous voir au champ car annoncer des
suppressions d'emploi je pense qu'on est
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge heures
situation plutôt compliqué forcément si
vous souhaitez intervenir les uns et les
autres pour conclure sur ce sujet
peut-être si je pouvais si je pouvais
rebondir sur ce sujet auront comprend
parce qu'au début on a parlé des
retraités ensuite on a parlé des pertes
du personnel soignant puis puis des
enseignants est aujourd'hui des
commerces et donc de la vie économique
et on voit de la dila difficulté la deux
faire de la politique parce qu'il faut
il faut essayer de contenter tout le
monde de sauver le secteur économique en
même temps protéger les enseignants
protéger les personnels soignants et on
voit que c'est clairement impossible de
contenter de contenter tout le monde et
on voit la vraie difficulté à faire de
la politique
et pour parler des clayes-sous-bois nous
à radio sensations dimanche on reçoit
philippe duquesne donc le merde
dès que les dessous voix qui dans lyn
thériault nous dit très clairement que
l'huile et pour ces mesures de
confinement pour protéger sa population
mais qui quelques minutes plus tard
s'inquiète aussi et c'est normal en tant
qu'élu de la situation de ces commerces
locaux de la situation de personnes
permaswage excusez moi pour la
prononciation de l'entreprise qui est
basée sur les clés depuis les années 70
je crois ou 80 il ya 150 postes qui sont
menacés sur place et on voit là toute la
difficulté vraiment à réussir ce
confinement en france et dans les aider
c'est la pratique du en même temps voilà
satisfaits et qui m'a et oui on connaît
également la position du président du
département car bédié qui lui était
favorable au maintien de l'ouverture des
commerces autant que faire se peut pour
éviter l'hécatombe économique donc
quelque part c'est un choix comme vient
de le dire nicolas quasiment impossible
entre la la mort économique ou bien la
mort physique sanitaire des personnes
donc etc c'est la première fois dans
notre histoire qu'on se retrouve
confronté à une telle situation
donc pour évaluer la dangerosité de
l'exposition frein du maintien de
l'ouverture d'un petit commerce
on n'a pas être on n'a pas vraiment
d'éléments donc là c'est un principe de
précaution qui s'applique et je pense
que c'est pour ça que certains maires
s'aventure dans le maintien dans la
prise d'arrêtés bien qu'ils les gros
mais qui se disent bon bah on joue le
tout pour le cours de pierre bédier
l'ensemble des maires d'île de france 1
cosigné un courrier qu'ils ont adressé
effectivement gouvernement pour parler
de la situation des tous ces petits
commerces
nous allons refermer cette page
consacrée à la partie du confinement
pour ce club de la presse de ce mois ci
et nous allons passer aux autres sujets
qui font l'actualité dans le département
[Musique]
et malheureusement dans l'actualité il
est aussi question de la menace
terroriste juste au début des vacances
de la toussaint le professeur d'histoire
au collège ça mais elle pâtit était
décapité en pleine rue pour avoir parlé
lors d'un cours de la liberté
d'expression après l'émotion à peine le
temps de s'interroger de trouver des
réponses adaptées qu'un nouvel attentat
a été perpétré
du côté de nice les uns et les autres
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est dans une
situation véritablement explosive avec
un danger un peu à chaque coin de rue
sans entrer dans une angoisse et une
paranoïa mais ce que ce danger
ces inquiétudes sont réelles où c'est
plus des faits isolés comme sur le
terrain nouradine par exemple du côté de
deux trappes
je m'adresse à vous parce que l'on sait
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de départs aussi
il ya quelques années pour la syrie donc
forcément trappe et sylvie l'exposé
pourrait effectivement selon les
chiffres entre 60 et 80 et 81 des par
mois ce qui va je vais essayer de vous
répondre un peu plus globalement
wilfried parce que c'est quelque chose
que j'entends assez rarement dans toutes
les analyses qui peuvent être faits sur
ces sujets il me semble connaître sur
une analyse plutôt plutôt avec avec un
biais très très très rétrécit ce qui se
passe directement sur notre territoire
mais qui ne manque un petit peu une
vision en géopolitique un petit peu plus
globale
les attentats sont liées à une situation
géopolitique mondiale très compliqué et
notamment à une confrontation à laquelle
la france participe bien entendu par
rapport à tous les mouvements jihadistes
qui peut y avoir en syrie au mali en
irak et dans d'autres territoires et je
pense que tant que cette situation ne
sera pas réglée et bien
en france dans d'autres pays européens
ou même dans le premier pays concerné
puisque les attentats frappe
principalement les pays que j'ai cités
tout à l'heure qui sont que sont à cyril
irak afghanistan ou encore d'autres pays
tant que cette situation ne sera pas
réglée à dire qu'on ne sera pas à l'abri
ici dans notre pays d'ailleurs le
ministre de la terre et le ministre le
premier ministre l'ont annoncé également
il y aura d'autres attentats d'ailleurs
il y en a qui sont qui seront des jouets
déjouer tous les jours donc je pense que
cette peur est les dents dans la tête en
tout cas de beaucoup de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens
mais je suis d'accord également avec ce
que vous avez dit faut pas non plus
tomber dans la dans une sorte de
paranoïa que la peur soit présente
certes mais je pense que les ce que ce
que les gens en tout cas que je vois me
rattrape ont envie c'est qu'on continue
de vivre et que ce soit là peut-être la
meilleure réponse à apporter à celles et
ceux qui voudraient remettre cela en
question
un élément que nous ravit bien de dire
et qui est très important c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'attentes à qui sont des
jouets tous les jours et on n'est pas au
courant parce que c'est ce sont des
informations qui sont classés en tout
cas sur le territoire des yvelines le
renseignement territoriale des yvelines
est actif tous les jours est mobilisé en
permanence et ce qui est dommage c'est
de la part d'une enquête menée par
marianne le magazine marianne
hebdomadaire a mis en cause un leur
enseignement territoriale des yvelines
par rapport à l'attentât de conflans
sainte honorine
ils ont cité une note en fait une note
de service du lundi 12 octobre qui a été
remontée qui a été envoyé à la dgs et
dans cette note on voit que il ya toutes
les informations donc la dgs y avait
connaissance de ce qui s'était passé
dans cette école par rapport à ce cours
d'histoire géographie dans les
conclusions de la note on voit que
finalement il ya les personnes les
personnes qui ont été impliquées des
personnes mises en examen sont cités
dans cette note
l'information a été transmise à la dgs
ivg hasina vous voyez aucune information
aux renseignements territoriale des
yvelines pour dire il faut maintenir cet
établissement
sous surveillance il peut y avoir des
risques parce qu'il ya des personnes qui
sont fichés est quand même qui rôdent
autour de cet établissement et marianne
en fait dénoncer le fait que leur
enseignement territoriale des yvelines
n'avait pas fait son boulot en quelque
sorte parce que il n'avait pas et
surveiller le l'établissement mais il
n'avait eu aucun retour de la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure pour
maintenir une surveillance autour de cet
établissement sur les réactions des
politiques parce que c'est de là aussi
d'où peut venir une certaine manière la
solution des décisions qui sont prises
des actions qui sont menées est ce que
les réactions des politiques nous ont
semblé adéquat chacun qui vont se
prononcer oui non mais c'est compliqué
wilfrid parce que c'est un sujet vous le
savez dès qu'il ya un attentat il ya une
boîte de pandore comme ça qui s'ouvre et
puis on a le droit à soit l'opposition
qui a des solutions qui auraient fait
mieux que tout le monde soit les
personnes qui sont en place qui à mon
sens ce mélange beaucoup de choses mais
c'est ce que disait nicolas tendre est
intéressant à l'instant au niveau de la
dgs y ait de la manière dont nous sommes
protégés contre ces actes terroristes
j'ai appris hier que l'attentât qui a eu
lieu à vienne une part par une personne
qui avait été fichier s qui avait tenté
de partir en syrie et que finalement et
que même les services slovaque avait
envoyé une note aux services de
renseignement autrichien pour dirk
attention à quelques que cette personne
qui avait tenté de partir en syrie avait
acheté des munitions
alors évidemment ceux qui écoutent ça et
qui nous qui nous suit vont dire bah
qu'est ce qui s'est passé concrètement
et puis ça peut même nourrir voilà
toutes les thèses complotistes qui
circule beaucoup bon bah on laisse faire
on laisse faire on laisse faire donc
voilà c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
questions
marianne l'a soulevée dans un article ce
ne sont pas les seuls mediapart
également mais voilà toutes ces
questions sont très compliquées le très
complexe et manque de nuance dans notre
débat et quand on entend que même les
spécialistes du terrorisme français les
universitaires refuse d'aller sur les
plateaux de télé parce qu'à partir du
moment où ils vont apporter un peu de
nuance on va dire ben vous êtes avec
nous ouvrez votre contre nous
ça explique tout tout ce qu'on entend
dans les réponses politiques qui ont été
apportées voilà la vie culturelle et les
nuances n'existe plus voilà on est
vraiment c'est pour ou contre il ya dans
la nuance aujourd'hui on la descente
pour moi la nuance la nuance est morte
dans le débat public en tout cas pour
l'instant la question tout de même
acquis malaisie puis après j'aimerais
qu'on parle aussi des actions qui sont
menées sur le terrain et qui en cette
période de confinement ne peuvent plus
être mené tout l'aspect social l'aspect
éducation aussi à qui m'a alors nous
cette semaine où l'on rencontrait une
nouvelle fois le maire de comps plantes
bien entendu l'attentât et est encore
dans tous les esprits et après le
recueillement en tout cas ce qui nous a
d'ores et déjà annoncé sais que dans les
semaines à venir il
il va rencontrer l'ensemble des
différents acteurs des communautés
religieuses des associations éducatives
et de différents experts en prévention
la radicalisation pour s'assurer que le
travail de convergence vers les valeurs
de la république du gouvernement évoque
très régulièrement ces derniers temps
est toujours effectif
il est aussi en attente de davantage de
mesures de contrôle sur internet et
notamment sur sur les réseaux sociaux
j'en reviens à cette question du travail
de terrain et vous le mener à l fm aussi
vous organiser des ateliers vous allez
rencontrer les jeunes publics ça fait
partie de tout ce travail d'éducation
aussi des plus jeunes pour ne pas
arriver dans des situations dramatiques
comme celle qu'on vit actuellement tout
ce travail ne peut plus être menée
actuellement par exemple à l fm les
ateliers les rendez vous vous organisez
vous pouvez encore les maintenir alors
le travail pédagogique a
considérablement baissé notamment depuis
le début du confinement donc depuis le
début de la semaine
c'est un travail qui lancé à distance
mais oui ça a été on est dans une
période effectivement ou de fait on va
être plus isolé en raison du confinement
où les acteurs de terrain
alexandre par exemple sur sur les
yvelines sur saint quentin en yvelines
vous ont fait part aussi de leurs
inquiétudes et de ce manque de lien
social et éducatif
écoutez en ce moment j'ai l'impression
que oui à tout tout est contre tout est
compliqué au confinement
moi ce que je pouvais revenir c'était
sur les mesures qui ont été annoncées
par les médias le mac pro pour lutter
contre le séparatisme
j'ai rencontré hier une famille qui fait
de l'instruction en famille donc il ya
des scolarisés ses enfants pour mener
une situation à la maison et on fait
toutes les familles vont être impactés
par par la décision du président de la
république de supprimer l'instruction de
famille alors qu'elle sort m disait
beaucoup de familles sont concernées
beaucoup me disent que finalement les
séparatismes ça concerne juste une
minorité à l'instruction en famille donc
on peut voir que c'est oui c'est des
mesures très délicate à mettre en place
très compétitive si je pouvais peut-être
rebondir aussi sur la question sociale
que vous évoquiez wilfried je trouve
puisque vous vous demandiez aussi ce
qu'on pensait des réactions politiques
et on est dans un département très à
droite on le sait c'est que souvent le
volet sécuritaire est mise en avant et
on met de côté la question sociale qui
qui joue beaucoup on sait dans ces
questions là on évoquait les départs ont
tiré deux buts rap
si ça arrive à trappes c'est aussi parce
qu'il ya déjà beaucoup de difficultés
sociales et ça c'est du temps très long
dont on parle finalement très peu vous
évoquez aussi la question de l'éducation
qu'elle est les enfants ça prend du
temps aussi
j'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ya un attentat comme ça on pense au
court terme aux mesures sécuritaires qui
sont qui sont efficaces mais à très
court terme mais qu'est ce qu'on fait à
long terme pour empêcher qui est qui est
un type qui pète un câble excusez moi et
qui prennent un couteau et et qui avait
tué quelqu'un dans la rue ça c'est pas
en mettant des policiers partout dans la
rue qu'on va l'empêcher c'est aussi il y
a un volet social qui est très difficile
à définir et à ea ea
j'ai envie de dire à l'évoquer mais qui
auxquels il faut s'attaquer
dont on parle très peu quand il arrive
ce genre d'attentât en france et puis on
a vu hier vous et vous parliez manuel
d'emmanuel macron qui s'est déplacé à la
frontière franco espagnole
il a parlé du renforcement de gardes
frontières encore une fois on est sur le
volet sécuritaire important certes mais
pas suffisant je pense qu'aucune vernis
dernière chose sûre sur le séparatisme
ou une frite si j'ai le temps venu sur
notre secteur n'avait évidemment très
interpellé par le nombre de déplacements
ministériels et de deux membres du
gouvernement sur une ville telle que les
mureaux d'ailleurs le plan de contre le
séparatisme annoncé par emmanuel macron
s'est fait une fois de plus dans cette
ville ça pose la question de ce qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour des villes comme les
mureaux et puis pourquoi toujours dans
cette ville alors bien entendu on a
entendu là la réponse du maire de bureau
qui explique que sa ville est une ville
laboratoire et que c'est à ce titre là
que les différents membres du
gouvernement se rendre là-bas la réalité
nous ce qu'on observe c'est patent ça
c'est que c'est une ville où
effectivement il ya très peu de
diversité va parce qu'on va pas se le
cacher et en se mettant à la place des
gens qui habitent aux mureaux on peut
facilement se demander si si c'est pas
une ville classée comme étant à
problèmes et pour laquelle finalement
n'a pas vraiment de solution c'est vrai
que les gens il n'ya pas de mixité là
bas mais qu'est ce qu'on attend de la
population qu'est ce qu'on attend pour
aller vers davantage de mixité en
réalité les choses ont été structurés
organisés depuis des nombreuses années
et c'est très compliqué maintenant en
2020 d'arrivée et d'expliquer qu'il ya
un problème de thé par atis mme sur une
ville comme les bureaux merci à tous
pour vos interventions à c'est toujours
assez intéressant d'entendre les
différents échos est toujours assez
assez pertinent on va changer un kit est
un petit peu ce le département des
yvelines
il n'y a pas vraiment de transition mais
parler d'un autre sujet parce que ça
passionne tous les français aussi les
yvelinois sélections américaines et des
expatriés qui vivent dans ce département
des yvelines
et nicolas landry vous en avez rencontré
d'ailleurs et il suivait un moment où
nous réalisons cette émission on ne sait
pas encore lequel des deux candidats
john trap l'a emporté ils sont en fait
les franco-américains à vivre dans les
yvelines
du fait de l'heure de leur densité
ils ont même organisé à saint germain en
laye des petits moments de réunion pour
permettre d'être conseillés sur le vote
comment voter depuis l'étranger et donc
b ils ont ils ont voté finalement par
correspondance avec différents systèmes
en fonction des états dans lesquels ils
sont rattachés
et puis on va les écouter parce qu'ils
ont vécu vraiment cette soirée
électorale
depuis leur domicile pour voter c'est
pas juste un jour même si je suis locaux
locales ici je me sens presque comme
européenne qui regarde ça de loin
j'ai une autre façon de voir les choses
et du coup je me sens que je suis
presque pas j'ai pas un américain
typique pour a
pour répondre à la question elle peut
voir ben voilà en fait on voit que ils
sont loin de leur pays mais ils ont
quand même un ressenti c'est important
on voit que l'une des expatriés dit que
des décisions prises par le prochain
président peut avoir des impacts
notamment au niveau de la fiscalité
puisque peu importe le pays dans lequel
un américain vie payer des impôts aux
états unis les expatriés qui suivent
s'appuient les yvelines lors les
yvelinois oscille et les français aussi
ou alors c'est peut-être les médias
quelques fois qu'ils en font trop on va
pas en tout cas nous s'attarder trop sur
ce sujet là mais c'était juste pour
faire plus un clin d'oeil sur cette
actualité là chez nos voisins européens
par exemple là on quitte carrément le
département des yvelines mais là nicolas
quillet lovitz vous intervenez pour
radio sensations mais vous intervenez
aussi sur notre antenne régulièrement
pour l'émission 7,8 europe nos voisins
européens se passionnent aussi comme les
français en tout cas est ce que les
médias européens se passionnent pour
cette élection
oui oui c'est partout la même la même
chose les télés les radios qui tournent
en boucle sur les élections américaines
peut-être encore plus à l'est de
l'europe parce qu'on le sait la relation
entre entre les pays de l'est et et les
états unis d'amérique sont sont plus
forte du fait des craintes notamment
d'une expansion de la russie donc à
cette alliance militaire qui est plus
forte avec plus de soldats américains
qui sont basés à l'est de l'europe donc
là les élections américaines sont
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus suivie
encore que en france ou ailleurs et puis
peut-être un un coup de gueule entre
guillemets d'un journaliste européen qui
est qui se demande toujours pourquoi les
médias nationaux et ce dans toute
l'europe s'intéresse plus aux élections
américaines qu aux élections européennes
n'ont pas que les élections mike
américaines ne sont pas importantes
parce que c'est quand même la première
puissance économique et militaire du
monde donc sera forcément un impact sur
notre avenir à tous mais je crois aussi
que le parlement européen et la
commission européenne ont un impact dans
la vie de tous les jours des européens
et au moment des élections européennes
deux de mes 2019
dommage qu'on en ait pas autant parlé
parce que c'est un sujet majeur aussi et
on peut se demander encore pourquoi il
ya cette différence de traitement entre
les élections américaines sur lesquels
on ne peut pas interférer et les
élections européennes auxquelles on vote
chacun chacun d'entre d'entre nous tout
à l'heure je parlais des médias
qui en font peut-être trop noir dean
faisait vue largement opiné être
d'accord avec ça je pense que la réponse
à nicolas kirillovitch ça va être simple
la différence entre les élections
américaines alizés les états unis
allaient les élections européennes c'est
que l'élection américaine est incarné à
chaque fois avec deux personnages très
très très fort dont un qui est un grand
acteur américain donc qui a su jouer des
réseaux sociaux des médias qui étaient
dans la télé réalité à avant
donc je pense que ça ça alimente aussi
une certaine envie même si elles lui
font bien évidemment les médias qui
traitent ça ne font pas ça que pour le
spectacle ou pour ce que ça peut
apporter en terme d'audimat mais en tout
cas les élections américaines ont certes
un rôle
c'est la première puissance mondiale
mais bon les élections européennes
on l'a vu les les françaises et les
français connaissent pas trop leurs
députés européens savent pas trop à quoi
ça sert donc c'est difficile d'en faire
quelque chose d'un peu sexy à la télé
contrairement à ce qui est fait aux
états unis alors en tout cas ce que ce
que je peux dire le sport pour rebondir
là dessus c'est vrai que c'est bon le
rôle des députés européens et méconnu
c'est probablement du fait des
institutions européennes très très
complexe mais mais même s'ils sont
méconnus le pouvoir politique de la
commission européenne et du parlement
européen sont dans la vie des européens
bien supérieur au pouvoir poétique du
président américain donc
donc il faut il faut je pense
s'interroger l'union européenne doit
s'interroger sur le pourquoi ces
parlementaires sont si peu connu et les
médias sur sûr comme le disait nouradine
pourquoi on s'intéresse plus à un combat
de boxe de boxe entre entre deux mal
entre guillemets candidats aux élections
américaines qu'une qu'une élection qui
se passe très bien dans 27 pays
européens
vous parlez nouradine tout à l'heure de
ses élus européens qu'on ne connaît pas
pour pour la plupart ne sais pas qui ils
sont c'est aussi vrai quelques fois pour
les élus locaux je ne suis pas sûr que
tous les habitants du département si on
leur demandait les noms de leurs députés
de leurs conseillers régionaux de leurs
conseillers départementaux
il serait très à même de pouvoir
répondre à l'est on verra si les
élections régionales départementales
sont maintenus en mars prochain ça
dépendra de la situation sanitaire la
décision n'a pas encore été prise mais
on verra et la participation et puis ce
serait intéressant d'aller voir si les
uns les autres connaissent déjà le nom
des sortants voilà en dehors de ceux qui
peuvent être quelquefois plus médiatique
revenons sur ce secteur des yvelines qui
tombent les élections américaines
le club de la presse qui se poursuit
avec notre rubrique personnalité du mois
avant de vous présenter nos
personnalités du mois les choix des
journalistes des yvelines nous devions
bien évidemment prendre le temps de
nommer celui dont tout le monde parlait
à qui tout le monde pense ces dernières
semaines sa mère pattie professeur
d'histoire de 47 ans décapité en
tranchées lui pour avoir abordé et
quelques jours plus tôt les caricatures
de mahomet tu as lors d'un cours avec
ses élèves de collège
nos pensées vont également à sa famille
son fils également de 5 ans bientôt
pupille de la nation comme l'a annoncé
depuis le ministre de l'éducation
nouradine nous allons débuter par vous
et votre personnalité du mois
alors ma personnalité du mois c'est
laurent qui est le gérant de la
librairie le pavé du canal de saint
quentin en yvelines dont il atteint
montini et par lui c'est un peu toutes
les librairies indépendantes que j'ai
voulu mettre à l'honneur nicolas nicolas
on a parlé tout à l'heure on n'est qu'à
la donnerait on a parlé tout à l'heure
dans l'introduction de l'émission voilà
des librairies qui sont mises à rude
épreuve et qui sont dans une sorte de
concurrence très déloyale avec notamment
les géants de l'it commerce
donc voila c'était l'occasion de mettre
en avant si libraires qui ont roué qui
ont vraiment connu un regain de succès a
juste après le confinement et voilà
qu'ils ont fait des points de retrait
des livraisons donc c'est l'occasion de
les mettre en avant et puis de faire
marcher aussi le marché et l'économie
locale
alexandre marqué pour les nouvelles 7,8
actu oui donc moi je voulais mettre en
avant le père etienne des ruptures ena
paroisse de trappes qui malgré ce
tableau compliqué pour
pour lui et pour tout le monde tente de
multiplier les initiatives à la sortie
du premier confinement il avait l'avait
remercié tous ceux qui avaient travaillé
pendant le confinement en distribuant
des des sables et des gâteaux dans
l'inconnu notamment aux commerçants
il ya quelques jours à l'occasion de là
tout ça il voulait organiser une grande
messe sous le chapiteau d'un cirque
installé dans la commune pour égayer un
peu le quotidien des gens et puis pour
aider le monde du cirque qui avait
beaucoup souffert du confinement dont la
messe a été finalement annulée à cause
du confinement et est là donc il a
continué ce week-end pour rendre hommage
aux chrétiens qu'elle a été assassinée à
nice il a organisé une plantation d'un
olivier de la paix dans l'église et un
stockage y en a il avait réuni 1
la municipalité on que le maire et puis
toutes les communautés religieuses de la
ville donc il s'est hissé bouger là il a
fait parler fait pas mal de choses ou
quotidien ouais c'est ça que vous voulez
mettre en avant si vous parlez des
différents hommages ont été rendus
notamment au lendemain de l'attentât de
de nice n'aura dit nous y avait consacré
un reportage sur l'antenne de marmites
vous avez rencontré le père etienne on
va l'écouter justement en fait devant
devant ces événements horribles qui ont
eu lieu à
à nice un moment il faut réagir aussi
appeler un chat un chat et puis surtout
être plus fort que les passions tristes
qui sont dans nos coeurs et voilà le
politique faits sont ce qu'il a à faire
la police fait ce qu'elle a à faire mais
nous on est des communautés de
territoires de proximité les religions
les associations un conseil municipal on
est au niveau du terrain et là nous
notre mission c'est de ces de pouvoir
vraiment tisser des liens fraternels
c'est essentiel sinon moi je suis très
inquiet pour demain très inquiet pour
l'avenir mais je suis pas sans espérance
peut-être parce que je suis croyant et
je suis chrétien mais je sais que si on
s'engage les uns les autres
eh bien eh bien on peut on peut à
nouveau tisser une belle vie ensemble et
je pense que le ce matin c'est le signe
d'une vie ensemble qui est heureuse est
possible et voilà donc ça d'être un peu
modélisant pour les mois et les années à
venir
voilà j'espère que cet olivier va
pousser très haut et qui sera plus qu'un
symbole qui la khadra vraiment la
réalité d'une ville où il fait bon
pousser ensemble faire grandir nos
familles ensemble
voilà pour cette intervention du père
etienne attrape c'était sur l'antenne de
marmites fm acquis mahaya pour l fm 95 5
vous aussi vous mettez un prêtre à
l'honneur ce mois ci oui il s'agit du
père williamson s'est c'est le curé qui
officie à la collégiale de
mantes-la-jolie et l'organisait le le
1er novembre dernier avec le maire de
mantes la jolie
elle connaît une messe en hommage aux
victimes des attentats de lys et de
conflans sainte honorine et on l'a
choisi parce qu'au delà du message aux
fidèles portent un message très
fédérateur empreint de courage à lui se
refuse à faire
la peur et puis surtout d' appel à
l'unité des messages qu'on a qu'on a
besoin d'entendre en ce moment qu'ils
sont de plus en plus rares dans ce cas
de troubles comme un extrait je sais pas
si on va prévu d'écouté mais en tout cas
c'est la personnalité du mois oui on va
on va l'écouter aussi également le
perdre ce qui s'est passé à nice qui
s'est passé aussi à conflans nous
meurtri particulièrement en finlande
et on est abasourdi par tout ce qui
s'est passé par cette violence cette
haine et en même temps je crois qu'il
faut pas rentrer dans une psychose dans
une peur parce que céder à la peur c'est
céder aux forces du terrorisme
je ne veux pas céder à la peur je pense
qu'il faut simplement continuer à vivre
et à vivre les uns avec les autres
parce qu'on a quelque chose à dire par
rapport à le fait d'être très différents
dans notre société aujourd'hui
multiculturelle multireligieuse on a à
dire qu'il est possible de vivre
ensemble enfin à le dire et à le montrer
sur tout et j'ai été très touché par les
communautés musulmanes qui sont venus
nombreux
j'étais très touché par les autres
communautés chrétiennes et puis voilà
tout un chacun
peut-être même des non croyants qui sont
venus simplement pour rendre hommage
et ça ce sont des signes qui sont
concrets qui sont réelles alors c'est
sûr un attentat ça fait énormément de
bruit tout le monde en parle mais les
gestes simples de vie ensemble du
quotidien à sa personne n'en parle mais
c'est ça l'essentiel
voilà pour l'intervention du père
william somme c'était sur l'antenne de
mfm et puis je leur précise pour ceux
qui nous suivent qui suivent cette
émission sur les antennes de nos
partenaires que ce soit marc minitel fm
ou encore radio sensations la radio
sensations justement nicolas
kirillovitch vous c'est une profession
dont on parle peu et son représentant
que vous mettez à l'honneur ce mois ci
oui c'est erwan saoudi délégué général
fo pénitentiaire est un peu comme
nouradine tout à l'heure au lieu au delà
de parler de lui précisément qu'on a
reçues en plateau sur à sensation
récemment et dont on peut voir
l'interview sur notamment sur notre
chaîne youtube c'est l'intérêt du sujet
qui je pense prévaut sur sur ce coup là
parce qu'on parle très peu de la
situation des prisonniers et puis des
personnels qui travaillent en prison on
sait qu'il ya des mutineries lors du
premier confinement puisque les visites
au parloir n'était pas possible
aujourd'hui salle les mais c'est un
sujet très complexe puisque les risques
sanitaires sont démultipliés en prison
où les aigles enfin je veux dire la
situation hygiénique des prisons n'est
pas toujours n'est pas toujours optimale
pour le moins qu'on puisse dire donc
dans ce témoignage voilà ils nous
racontent comment ça se passe en prison
comment comment ils font pour aussi
calmer quelques situations comment eux
se protège et puis sur en prison et puis
quelques chiffres à vous donner
puisqu'on parle très peu de ce sujet la
part pour parler des éventuelles
mutinerie au problème ce sont le nombre
de personnes qui sont atteintes du coc
vide dans l'est dans les prisons
françaises selon les derniers chiffres
de la direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire il y à 182 détenus et 44
cents cinquante et un agent qui sont
positifs sur 61 mille détenus en france
ça peut paraître peu mais bon dans en
prison c'est si un cluster c'est
beaucoup difficile beaucoup plus
difficile à contrôler d'ailleurs dans la
dans la population donc voila c'était
pour mettre le zoom sur sur un métier
puis sur une situation en particulier et
l'entretien est à revoir vous l'avez dit
sur la chaîne youtube de radio
sensations nous passons au sujet bientôt
à la une dans vos différents médias
alexandre pour 7,8 actus.fr les
nouvelles de votre côté une actualité
qui concerne la commune des
clayes-sous-bois et le devenir du de la
halle du marché des clayes-sous-bois
c'est en fait là le marché un nouveau
marché aurait dû ouvrir depuis plusieurs
semaines mais il n'a pas pu ouvrir pour
une cause c'est qu'en fait il ya un
problème de portes de coupe feu qui n'a
pas été vu en fait par le maître
d'oeuvre ou ce qui a eu le don de rendre
furieux le maire de la commune fils
dylan et du coup un peu de ça il ya
plusieurs commissions de sécurité qu'on
a pu être ça puisse les lire donc les
pigments ne peut pas ouvrir le maire a
donc mis en demeure le maître d'oeuvre
d'effectuer les travaux dans les plus
brefs délais si tout rentre dans l'ordre
ça pourrait ouvrir avant noël la
première quinzaine de décembre
et on va voir les unes de vos deux
éditions papier sur rambouillet et sur
versailles
les deux éditions qui bien évidemment
reviennent sur ce re confinement
noureddine à présent pour marmite
fm votre sujet bientôt à la une l'un des
sujets que vous allez aborder
prochainement on va passer toute la
semaine prochaine wilfried
avec une spéciale de semaine des
écrivains persécutés empêcher
emprisonnés c'est une journée mondiale
en fait à la journée des écrivains en
prison qui a lieu le 15 novembre
donc ce sera dimanche dimanche prochain
voilà pour mettre à l'honneur des
écrivains et journalistes les poètes
artistes généralement qui subissent des
ré près des représailles qui sont soit
mis en prison soit poussé à l'exil soit
dans les cas extrêmes qui sont tués pour
ce qu'ils ont pu publier ou dire voilà
donc on est partenaire de cet événement
et puis le 15 novembre à 17 heures il
rend un facebook live justement avec
trois invités que vous pourrez retrouver
donc sur le site kiosque de saint
quentin en yvelines nicolas kirillovitch
sports radio sensations il ya deux
événements à venir aussi spéciaux sur
sur votre antenne le premier plutôt
festif sensation en scène
c'est ça la sensation en scène donc
c'est une émission qui avait été lancée
avant le premier confinement il y aura
une nouvelle version le mardi 17
novembre qui sera qui sera diffusée à
21h c'est une émission de divertissement
où il ya des différents artistes qui qui
s'enchaînent qui font des performances
qui sont aussi interviewé ça a été
enregistré avec dans les règles
sanitaires évidemment au cabaret du bout
des prêts à cerner la ville avec avec
des journalistes de sensations il y aura
notamment des artistes tels tony bastion
car la forêt aussi julien dassin le fils
de joe dassin pour revenir enfin pour
évoquer aussi les 40 ans de la
disparition de l'artiste donc ça c'est
le mardi 17 novembre et la semaine
suivante le 24 novembre une autre
émission spéciale pour faire le bilan
d'un mois de nouveau confinement on a
une nouvelle fréquence je ne sais pas si
vous êtes au courant et qui a ouvert à
paris numérique
donc on sera en direct du moulin à café
dans le 14e arrondissement pour recevoir
différentes différents acteurs du monde
économique politique sociale pour
évoquer c'est à moi et puis
faire un peu de perspective sur sur noël
pour voir ce qu'il en est pour tous ces
différents acteurs ça sera le 24
novembre
depuis le moulin à café un restaurant
associatif dans le 14e arrondissement de
paris on est vous spécial fin de
confinement de confinement on l'espère
sans prolongation hakima à présent pour
l effet rendez vous spécial aussi avec
une mobilisation contre la haine c'est
ça la semaine tous unis contre la haine
en partenariat avec l'adil crastes une
opération m'organise déjà depuis trois
ans cette année ça se passe du 9 au 13
novembre habituellement l'été autour d
un terme ars et je voudrais
internationale consacrée aux luttes
contre les discriminations
cette année au vu du confinement on a
été contraint en mars dernier de la
pauvreté et au vu de l'actualité de ce
qui a touché notre secteur de couverture
notamment sur couplant la rédaction a
choisi de la reprogrammer avec tous les
jours de 11h à 12h des émissions
spéciales à une semaine de programmation
pour des sujets liés à l'ald les
discriminations et pour le vivre
ensemble avec l'intervention de
différents acteurs du monde associatif
comme la ligue des droits de l'homme
aussi des références en prévention de la
radicalisation sur le territoire des
entretiens d'élus comme comme laurent
bros même si chaque jour des
associations qui oeuvrent spécifiquement
pour la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
contre le racisme ou encore contre la
haine anti lgbt et pour terminer un mot
sur l'actualité de tv 78 nicolas landry
je profite de votre présence pour
évoquer le sky écho au rendez-vous deux
fois par mois pour un point sur
l'actualité économique du territoire
wilfrid et le prochain numéro c'est
vendredi 13 novembre
on ira à la rencontre de commerçants de
saint quentin en yvelines et on
rencontrera aussi une salariée qui a été
recruté juste avant le confinement pour
savoir comment s'est passé son
intégration alors que le confinement
débuté merci nicolas landry pour tv 78
merci aussi aux différents acteurs
journalistes du département
pour cette 8 actus.fr les nouvelles
marmite elles fm radio sensations
plateau plutôt complet ce mois ci on se
retrouve très bientôt sur les
différentes antennes de vos médias très
bon courage à tous et puis profiter
profitez en pour prendre soin de vous
aussi
[Musique]